all right today we're going to talk
about how to burn off belly fat
as fast as possible and this video is
for beginners and i'm going to show you
the basics of how to do it but
there's some very important details that
you need to know there's actually five
vital and practical tips
that
you don't really find in books
and i've discovered these just with
experience working with so many people
for so many years so i'm going to break
it down i'm going to make it very very
simple because so many people get
overwhelmed with all these details of
how to do keto it's over complicated and
then some people just kind of give up so
let me just show you the five most
important things to focus on so you can
be very very successful right from the
beginning and not end up where a lot of
people end up where they get this
plateau and they just can't seem to
get past a certain point so it's always
very very important to learn from other
people's mistakes so you don't have to
make them and in this video i just want
you to get the very important things
you're going to have other questions
for those questions and additional
details i have a million videos you can
watch later but at least let's get you
started with the most important tips
now what is the goal of getting on the
ketogenic plan
the goal is to bring your insulin levels
as low as possible that is the goal if
your insulin levels are low you have a
maximum fat burning you have maximum
ketosis
ketosis is a state of producing ketones
ketones are the byproduct of fat burning
and so the more ketones you generate the
more fat you're going to burn
and the faster you're going to lose your
mid section now at the very top level of
keto we have these macros we have
carbohydrates and you want to keep your
carbs between
people say between 30 and 50 grams but
i'm going to tell you keep them below 20
grams or less especially if you want to
speed things up and then we have protein
we want to keep that between
three to six ounces of protein per meal
but that varies depending on your size
and your metabolism and your age and how
many meals you're consuming if you're
just doing omad one meal a day obviously
you're gonna be doing more protein
if you're a bodybuilder if you're
exercising a lot you're gonna need a
little bit more but for the average
person
just consume the amount of protein per
meal the size of the palm of your hand
okay that's it i just want to keep it
really really simple now as far as fat
goes
you're going to be consuming 75 of your
calories of fat now what does that mean
75 of your calories
how much is that in grams or ounces
so for this video i'm not going to get
into the complexities of measuring
different grams to get your macros so
when i explain the tips
you'll understand how much fat you'll
need all right tip number one instead of
counting
your grams of carbs
it's going to be much easier to consume
certain carbs
that you don't have to count okay
and i'm talking about leafy green
vegetables
salads because this is mostly fiber and
the insulin response is
almost zero because fiber is the only
carbohydrate that does not affect
insulin so when we're talking about
salad we don't have to be counting
carbohydrates in fact i want you to
consume
a larger amount of salad i want you to
consume at least seven cups of salad per
day it's not hard to do that and one
little tip on this point with salad to
make it easier to consume is we use a
salad cutter so we actually cut the
salad down so we have this bowl of salad
and then we cut it down and it just
makes it even smaller and it's easier to
consume so instead of trying to be
overwhelmed with all these carbs just
use vegetable carbohydrates okay like
salad and don't even worry about
counting your carbs and you can put
other things on it as well like feta
cheese
definitely put the olive oil or
vinaigrette and just make sure your
salad dressing has like i don't know
one or less carbs okay
there are so many salad dressings that
are out now that are virtually carb free
but there's so many other salad
dressings that are just loaded with
sugar and that could be a hidden problem
now why do we want to consume all this
salad well keto is all about being low
carb right
keto doesn't emphasize adding more
nutrients the type of keto that i always
recommend is the healthy version of
ketosis so we're not only reducing
insulin we're enhancing nutrients so you
can actually be healthier at the end of
the day there's huge benefits of
lowering your carb but there's also huge
benefits of having nutrient dense foods
and the thing that salad has is it has a
lot of potassium it has a lot of
magnesium
and it has a lot of vitamin c in
addition to other vitamins like vitamin
k1 and folic acid and has a lot of
phytonutrients which are those things
that go way beyond just the normal
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
but consuming this large amount of salad
on a keto plan
will give you these nutrients to prevent
keto cramps in your calves it can help
prevent keto fatigue keto flu
and it'll improve a condition called
insulin resistance so it'll help lower
insulin even more
and it'll even give you energy now as a
side note additional tip i always
recommend to do your salad first
if you do your salad first you'll
definitely not overeat your protein if
you eat your protein first and then your
salad i find a lot of people
can't seem to consume that much salad
after they eat the protein
now if you're having a hard time with
doing that much salad do what you can
and you can also enhance things with a
good electrolyte powder now i'm not
biased of my own electrolyte powder but
i will say that it is the highest
quality electrolyte on the market so the
tip number one is consume the salad at
the beginning part of your meal all
right number two protein there's a
couple practical things about protein
you need to know
um first of all maybe you want to start
with the protein the size of the palm of
your hand
and if you're a bigger person or a
younger person have more and if you're a
older person with a slower metabolism
have a little bit less if you have too
much protein
then you're going to find that you're
going to feel sluggish and that can slow
down your ketosis as well
now the same goes with not enough
protein you can feel too tired because
your body needs a certain amount of
protein now the key with protein is
don't do low fat protein find a protein
that has the most fat fat normally comes
with protein and so if you're going to
do a hamburger which i actually eat a
lot of hamburger
get the fattiest hamburger if you're
going to do fish don't get the leanest
fish do the salmon or even sardines both
of them are high in fat and that's going
to be much better than the lean protein
if you're going to do chicken don't just
do the skinless chicken breasts do the
parts of the chicken that have the skin
and the fat now why is that because when
you consume lean protein you stimulate
insulin a little bit more than if it was
fattier protein
in fact the thing that stimulates
insulin a very high level is whey
protein because there's hardly any fat
in whey and that's the type of protein
that i would not recommend but the point
is try to get
protein that comes with more fat pork
has a lot more fat than other types of
meat if you do steak try to eat the fat
that normally comes with the steak all
right that's tip number two now tip
number three is about fat now if you're
new to keto and you're just starting out
it's very important to increase the
amount of fat at each meal so that could
be consuming more nuts i like pecans but
you can do other types of nuts as well
you can do macadamia nuts you have
olives avocado you have more olive oil
on your salad you have mct oil but the
question is if you're eating all this
fat is that going to slow down weight
loss and the answer is
yes
because the initial goal of the
ketogenic plan is not necessarily to
jump right into weight loss
it is to do this and this is very very
important so if you've checked out just
check back in right now and really pay
attention to this next thing i'm going
to tell you it is
very very important
to also do intermittent fasting with
healthy keto
now why
well if you were to check your ketones
your blood ketones and the scale goes up
from zero all the way up to like seven
it can go a little bit higher but
roughly there's a scale right if you do
just keto without intermittent fasting
chances are you're not going to get
above
one two
maybe three okay your level of ketones
the higher the more ketosis the deeper
fat burning you're going to be in and
the lower in the scale the less you're
going to be into ketosis so if you
wanted to get your numbers
like four
five maybe six
you need to add in a minute fasting
and potentially even exercise but we're
not going to talk about exercise right
now we just want to talk about
intermittent fasting so the combination
of low carb and immune fasting together
is really powerful if you want fast
results getting rid of your belly fat
and to do that very easily
we don't want you to have an appetite we
don't want you to be hungry all the time
we don't want you to have cravings so
the first strategy or tip
to do this is to add more fat to the
meal
so you can go longer without eating so
you can start your in a minute fasting
pattern so the first goal is not to eat
breakfast okay to go as long as possible
and then have your first meal about 12
and your second meal at six
and then over time you'll squish these
two meals closer and closer and closer
and for some people you're just going to
like eliminate the lunch altogether and
just do the dinner so you're doing one
meal a day which is called omega now
when you eat this fat at the meal
you're going to be very satisfied okay
and within two to three days
you're not going to be hungry at all
you're going to lose your appetite
why
because you're able to fast longer and
you're going to be more into ketosis so
in other words your body is going to
start burning your own fat which is a
new concept for a lot of people but here
is the next point
don't eat if you're not hungry
so many people screw this up because
they're doing this robotic
they're told this how many meals that
you need to have per day and they're
doing low carb but they're not losing
weight and they're eating when they're
not even hungry
huge mistake if you're not hungry
don't eat why would you want to screw up
your fat burning i mean here you are you
finally lowered your carbs your body is
tapping into your fat it's getting rid
of the fat on your liver and your
midsection
and your appetite is gone because you
are eating when you're not eating
and then you eat a meal
and now
you're going to be hungry a little bit
later
because every time you eat
you pop yourself out of ketosis
regardless of what you eat just because
eating triggers insulin
and high insulin blocks the state of
ketosis this is why we do intermittent
fasting and this is why this rule is so
important so as soon as you start
getting into this adaptation where
you're burning your own fat and your
hunger goes away the next meal you start
cutting down your fat this mct oil
the extra nuts why would we want to do
this because and this especially applies
if you have a slow metabolism
if the body has a choice between dietary
fat
and its own fat
it's going to go after
and burn the dietary fat before your own
fat and what we're trying to do is to
get you to burn off your own belly fat
and so you don't want to go crazy with
too much fat while you're in the middle
of this plan in the very beginning part
of ketosis you want to increase fat and
at the very end of this cycle when you
reach your goal
that's when we also want to increase
your fat but not in the middle of this
program where you're just in fat burning
and you've lost your appetite you're not
craving everything's going great you
don't have to add a lot of fat
you just want to have the fat that
normally comes with the protein now you
definitely don't want to go low-fat
but just don't start adding all this
additional fat unless you have a high
metabolism when you're doing
intermittent fasting when you're doing
ketosis it's very important to include
all the nutrients that you need
to prevent nutritional deficiencies
because you're no longer going to be
doing
three meals and snacks and so if you're
gonna do two meals or one meal it's a
little more difficult to get your
nutrients and the fact that you're in
ketosis means that you're going to be
burning up
different nutrients the requirements of
certain nutrients are going to be higher
than they were before so you're going to
need more b vitamins
more electrolytes one of the good
sources of the b vitamins is nutritional
yeast and i'm not telling you you need
to consume my nutritional yeast you can
do any type of nutritional needs just
make sure it's not fortified with
synthetic vitamins but the b vitamins
are very very important
electrolytes are very important
and
sea salt is very very important if
you're not consuming extra sea salt
what's going to happen is you're going
to feel weak
make mental note of that and start
adding more sea salt to your diet now if
you're consuming a large salad
at that meal
the need for electrolytes will not be as
great because you're going to be getting
potassium and magnesium and other
minerals as well all right number five
we want to make this
a lifestyle change we want this to be
enjoyable
the fact that your cognitive function
is going to improve
your energy is going to improve
your mood is going to improve and your
belly is going to shrink is all going to
make you happier you're going to feel
better but a lot of people miss all
these
kind of pleasure foods and so there's a
couple things that
i include after a meal that you might
want to also include and one is a
low carb
chocolate you can do lilies chocolate
there's a lot of other chocolate
products that you can consume that have
low carb and but i tend to do a little
chocolate after my first meal not a
whole bar i might have a half a bar and
it's actually quite pleasurable the
other thing you can do not every meal
but maybe a few times a week is to make
some really cool
keto desserts and have one of those at
the end of the meal it's very very
pleasurable very enjoyable and i will
put a link down below of those recipes
and that way you can look forward to
having some healthy version of a dessert
so at this point if you do these basic
things these five things
you're going to notice some considerable
results but
you're going to still have questions and
i have a lot of
videos on the questions that you have
but i don't want you to get overwhelmed
with all these details and lost in the
woods
i want you to keep it really really
simple
and just jump in without having to learn
an entire book of details in fact i just
recommend that you start right now while
it's fresh in your mind and so if
questions come up just do a search i
have a video for every single question
you have but there's two more things i
want to mention
if something is working
don't change anything so many people go
along and they're getting great results
and then they change something why did
you change something it was working just
keep going but on the flip side if
something is not working then you need
to change something and for that
information i have a lot of videos on
plateau and i'll put some links down
below you can save those and then watch
them when you need them and the last
point and probably the most important
point
is this concept of you don't lose weight
to get healthy you have to get healthy
to lose weight
it's get healthy first
then the weight loss comes and that's
what we're trying to focus on the
healthy version of ketosis so to get
healthy and keep this really really
simple i created a very short playlist
of step one two and three that i want
you to watch right now check it out get
started immediately and send me your
success story